Democratic congresswoman Maxine Waters
of California is back not that she ever
went anywhere she recently got into a
fight on the floor of the house with
Republican Mike Kelly she said that car
dealers are racist here's part of it I
can't believe that in 2018 we're on the
floor of Congress seeing the denial of
some of my colleagues about
discrimination in the auto lending
business to impugn the integrity of the
automobile people is absolutely beyond
reproach and so if you run out of facts
I guess the next thing you have to go to
is discrimination
I am more offended as an
african-american woman than you will
ever be and this business about making
America great again it is your president
that's dividing this country I'm more
offended than you'll ever be
therefore I win in the who's offended
Olympics Maxine Waters is always a gold
medalist mark Stein that author and
columnist an all-purpose genius joins us
tonight and longtime kind of sure of
Maxine Waters so to me what's
fascinating is not that Maxine Waters
exists and maybe you kind of want people
like Maxine Waters around because it's
kind of hilarious but that she suddenly
become elevated to the status of hero in
the Democratic Party what does that tell
us yeah it's it's interesting to me that
she is not within the Democratic Party
as self-evidently ridiculous as the
creepy porn lawyer you were talking
about who I think I think actually he's
gonna be walking Meghan down the aisle
of Windsor Castle on Saturday Meghan
doesn't know it Meghan doesn't know it
but he's just decided to swing by and do
it because it'll work for him but the
interesting thing about Maxine Waters is
that this this is someone who for
example she's close friends with louis
farrakhan whom we've talked about before
who believes he's he's taken up in a
spacecraft to commune with the ghost of
elijah muhammad and various other fruit
of islam space aliens once a month i
don't know whether he takes Maxine up
there with him once a month although
would certainly explain a lot by the way
I would be in favor of that because if
the space aliens encounter Maxine Waters
and think she's a typical earthling they
will have no plans to
anywhere near this planet so they wish
you wouldn't they would be performing
useful service if they did that but it
is actually extraordinary to me this
for example she recently called Trump's
Hotel in Washington a criminal looking
hotel this is a woman who lives in a
four million dollar house and in that
sense sums up what Kanye West was
talking about the whole what are you
done what are you guys done for me
lately what at what has mortgaging the
entire future of one demographic group
to the likes of Maxine Waters actually
done for them and that's a question
that's more and more of asking so but
for garden-variety liberals who in
normal times would have a problem with
Maxine Waters ethics and her rhetoric
and she's a Democrats they're not gonna
criticize her in public but Maxine
Waters please she's too far they've
woken up in the last year and decided
that they really like Maxine Waters and
she speaks for them is there nobody on
the left who's saying well wait a second
that's too far she's too crazy but she
just credits us what are the reasonable
voices no I think that I think what's
interesting is that she made Time
Magazine's for anyone who wasn't aware
as a Time magazine is still out there
and still publishing every week she made
Time magazine's list of the 100 most
influential people in the world which is
patently absurd
Time magazine at a certain point used to
pretend to be internationally so they'd
have put you know the deputy fisheries
minister of the South Sandwich Islands
on the list because he's really making a
name for himself as a player in law of
the sea negotiations think that's how
time used to be instead they put Maxine
Waters on there who is totally an
influential except outside a very tiny
coterie of hardcore activists who chant
along with her when she says impeach 45
as she did recently at a memorial
service I mean I you know when they have
these organ donor cards saying if I get
killed in a fatal road accident give all
my body parts to somebody who needs them
I'm going to
carry a Maxine Waters card in my wallet
saying that if I get killed I don't want
her chanting impeach 45 at my memorial
service this has no appeal other than
beyond a very hardcore coterie but that
coterie is well-established them in the
media which is why Time magazine made
themselves look fools by putting her on
this most influential hundred people in
the world list
Trump has driven them insane it's humble
ends mark this moment mark Stein great
to see you as always